THAT IS THE LATEST FROM THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> COVID 19 IS SPREADING RAPIDLY
IN DALLAS COUNTY.
THE DATA IS CLEAR, ARE CASE
NUMBERS AND OUR HOSPITALIZATION
NUMBERS, THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TRACKING DAILY, ARE HEADED IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION.
>> THAT IS THE MAYOR OF DALLAS
TALKING ABOUT A SHOP INCREASE OF
CORONAVIRUS CASES THERE.
THAT IS ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
BIGGER PICTURE.
THE NUMBER OF CASES SURGING TO
MORE THAN 38,000 IN AMERICA
YESTERDAY.
THAT IS A RECORD DAILY HIGH.
IT SURPASSES THE PREVIOUS RECORD
THAT WAS SET TO MONTHS AGO.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SECRETARY
WELCOME BACK.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> WHAT IS YOUR PLAN?
>> WE ARE WORKING AGGRESSIVELY
WITH STATES AND LOCAL LEADERS IN
THIS SITUATION, BUT IT’S
IMPORTANT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT THIS IS A
LOCALIZED SITUATION.
THE COUNTIES THAT ARE IN HOT
SPOTS ARE 3 PERCENT OF AMERICAN
COUNTIES.
THAT’S NOT TO MINIMIZE THE
SITUATION, IT’S IMPORTANT TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF WHY WE ARE
SEEING THE SURGEON CASES NOW
PARRIED SOME OF IT CLEARLY HAS
TO DO WITH INCREASED TESTING.
WE TESTED OVER 30 MILLION PEOPLE
, THREE AND HALF MILLION
IN THE LAST WEEK, AND THE
AVERAGE AGE OF PEOPLE TESTING
POSITIVE IS GOING DOWN
DRAMATICALLY.
THAT MEANS WERE CAPTURING
YOUNGER ASYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS
WHICH IS A SIGN OF A ROBUST
TESTING SYSTEM THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS DELIVERED PARRIED WE
NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHY
WE SEE SUCH BREADING SO WEEP
DEPLOYED TEAMS TO THE COUNTY
LEVEL TO WORK WITH LOCAL LEADERS
AND COMMUNITY LEADERS TO FIGURE
OUT WHY WE ARE SEEING THIS KIND
OF SPREADING.
>> MISTER SECRETARY, THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THIS MORNING,
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW FIRST AND
FOREMOST IF THEY’RE GOING TO BE
SAFE OBVIOUSLY.
BUT IF THEY HAVEN’T RETURNED TO
WORK, THEY CERTAINLY WANT TOO.
IF THEY’RE BACK AT WORK, THEY
WANT TO STAY THERE.
AND THEY WANT TO KNOW IF THEIR
KIDS ARE GOING BACK TO SCHOOL IN
THE FALL.
DO YOU SEE ANOTHER SHUTDOWN
HAPPENING?
>> I DON’T, ALTHOUGH YOU WILL
SEE LOCAL COMMUNITY MITIGATION
STEPS DEPENDING ON CIRCUMSTANCES
.
AS I SAID, THE HOTSPOTS ARE IN 3
ABOUT 110 COUNTIES RIGHT NOW ARE
THE ONES WE ARE FOCUSED ON
PARRIED WE CAN GET BACK TO WORK,
BACK-TO-SCHOOL, BACK TO WORSHIP
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY BACK TO
HEALTH CARE IF WE ACT
RESPONSIBLY IS INDIVIDUALS.
IF WE KEEP IN MIND WHAT ARE OUR
INDIVIDUAL VULNERABILITIES.
MOST OF THE FATALITIES IN SEVERE
CASES ARE IN IN INDIVIDUALS 80
YEARS OR OLDER, OR 65 YEARS OF
AGE AND OLDER WITH DIABETES,
OBESITY, RENAL FAILURE, OR LUNG
DISEASE, THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TO BE REALLY PROTECTED
, THE REST OF US,
OBVIOUSLY SHOULD TAKE SENSIBLE
PRECAUTIONS, NONE OF US WANT TO
GET THIS DISEASE, BUT WE HAVE TO
PROTECT THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WE CAN GET BACK TO WORK, WE CAN
PRACTICE SOCIAL JUSTICE DEAN.
WE CAN WEAR FACEMASK IF WE CAN’T
PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING
PARRIED.
>> WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE,
YOU’RE TRYING TO GET OUT THERE
AND BE TRANSPARENT WITH THE
NATION, BUT YOU HAVEN’T HAD A
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE BRIEFING
IN A LONG TIME, SEVERAL WEEKS AS
YOU KNOW, FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS CRISIS
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR THE
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT, VICE
PRESIDENT, IN YOURSELF TO DEAL
DIRECTLY WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I’VE HEARD YOU NOW SAY IT’S A
LOCALIZED PROBLEM, DO SANDRA’S
QUESTIONS, I GET THAT THAT
HAPPENS ON THE LOCAL LEVEL, BUT
ARE YOU KIND OF FARMING THIS OUT
TO LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS?
>> NOT AT ALL, BUT IT’S ALSO A
LOCALLY LED FEDERALLY SUPPORTED
PROCESS OF RESPONDING PARRIED
YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT, THE
VICE PRESIDENT, MYSELF, WE’VE
GOT THE DOCTORS, THE FOUR
DOCTORS JUST SPENT SEVEN HOURS
TESTIFYING BEFORE CONGRESS THIS
WEEK, SO WE ARE OUT THERE, WE
ARE KEEPING THE INFORMATION
FLOWING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND ARE SUPPORTING OUR COUNTY
AND STATE LEADERS TO DEAL WITH
THIS WITH TRANSPARENT
INFORMATION.
IN GIVING THEM THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED FOR TO PRINT.
>> A PIECE IN THE NEW YORK TIMES
THIS MEAN SECRETARY AIDS ARE, I
WILL READ IT TO YOU.
WE NEED A CHURCHILL TO LEAD OUR.
INSTEAD WE HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT
FLOODS AND ENEMY VIRUS
INFILTRATE OUR HOMES PARRIED THE
TRUMP IS TRYING TO DECEIVE US.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT, THAT
THE PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP
THROUGH ALL OF THIS AND NOW
TALKS OF A POTENTIAL SECOND WAVE
, THAT WE COULD BE DOING
BETTER HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
TO GET THESE KIND OF PARTISAN
ATTACKS ARE AT COMPLETELY
RESPONSIBLE AS WE’RE IN A
PANDEMIC PAIRED OR WORKING
TOGETHER, THE PRESIDENT, VICE
PRESIDENT, I WE ARE WORKING WITH
GOVERNORS AND STATE LEADERS
REGARDLESS OF PARTY TO WORK FOR
THE BENEFIT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THINGS TO THE PRESIDENT’S
LEADERSHIP PRESIDENTS LEADERSHIP
, WE HAVE HISTORIC
TESTING SYSTEMS, WE HAVE
CONTAINMENT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
WE HAVE HOSPITAL SYSTEM CAPACITY
AND SUPPLIES FOR THEM.
WE’RE BRINGING THERAPEUTICS TO
MARKET, WE ARE DEVELOPING AT
RECORD SPEED, THAT IS ALL THANKS
TO THE PRESIDENT’S TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP, NOT JUST A WHOLE
GOVERNMENT APPROACH, BUT THE
WHOLE OF THE AMERICAN AUTONOMY
APPROACH TOGETHER ON THIS
PARRIED HE DESERVES CREDIT FOR
THAT AS WELL AS THE COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY THAT HE AND HIS
MINISTRATION HAVE PROVIDED TROUT
THIS CRISIS.
>> ON THE VACCINE QUESTION, YOU
SEEM TO BE SHOWING SOME OPTIMISM
PARRIED THE DOCTOR AND OTHER
SAID IT’S NOT A MATTER OF IF,
IT’S A MATTER OF WHEN I GUESS AS
THE WAY THEY WERE PUTTING IT
THEY ARE VERY CONFIDENT THAT IN
EARLY 2021, WE WILL HAVE A
VACCINE.
HOW OPTIMISTIC ARE YOU?
>> I’M OPTIMISTIC GIVEN THE
PRESIDENTS LEADERSHIP HERE.
WE ARE DEVOTING TREMENDOUS
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT WE
REDUCE ANY UNNECESSARY DELAY IN
DEVELOPING FA SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
VACCINE.
ALSO, WHERE MANUFACTURING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOSES OF
VACCINE AT RISK SO THAT THEY
WILL BE READY IF A VACCINE IS
APPROVED BY THE FDA PRETENDS OF
MILLIONS BY THE SMALL HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS BY EARLY NEXT YEAR.
>> SECRETARY, A CZAR, THAT FINAL
THOUGHTS ON JUST THE SECOND WAVE
, LISTENING TO YOU TALK
ABOUT THE VACCINE COMING IN
JANUARY, OBVIOUSLY FLU SEASON
COULD COME IN, WE ALL WANT TO
GET OUR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL
SAFELY.
DO YOU SEE THAT SECOND WAVE
HAPPENING?
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE X.
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S USEFUL TO
TALK ABOUT FIRST WAVE, SECOND
WAVE, WE JUST NEED TO DEAL WITH
IT ON THE GROUND.
RIGHT NOW 3 PERCENT OF CASES ARE
DEALING WITH RISING CASES AND WE
WANT TO DEAL WITH THEM.
WE AS THE SIX TOOLS I TALKED
ABOUT, SURVEILLANCE, TESTING,
CONTAINMENT, HEALTH SYSTEM
RESILIENCE, AND THERAPEUTIC.
WE HAVE THERAPEUTICS WERE
WORKING WITH, WE HAVE
CONVALESCENT PLASMA, WE HAVE
STEROIDS, AND WE WILL KEEP
BRINGING OTHER PRODUCTS TO
MARKET SO WE CAN KEEP REDUCING
OUR FATALITY RATE PARRIED ANY
DEATH AS TOO MANY.
BUT WE NOW HAVE FATALITIES IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR OVER 16
DAYS BELOW 1,000 AND A RATE OF
FATALITY PER MILLION PUTS US AT
THE TOP TIER OF DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF THE PERFORMANCE THEY
ARE IN PROTECTING VULNERABLE